and I think the evidence is really clear
this was a man-made disaster it wasn't a
natural disaster even though the storm
came in and went out we have many of
those it's when the levees broke that
the city was compromised so now post
Katrina we have a 14.5 billion dollar
levee system that is built to category
three solid it's a solid as a category
three today what would happen it would
be we'd be safe we'd be fine under
Katrina situations Katrina was a five
when it came in and when a three and
then it was actually down to a one but
it's because of the levees broke the
levees are much stronger than they were
before now it's a risk reduction
strategy it's not a guarantee bigger
storms are coming our way and by the way
New Orleans is really the nation's
canary in the coalmine we're really an
example to Miami to New York which
suffered this through Sandy that when
these big events come in Iowa be they
natural disasters man-made disasters
terrorist attacks you have to build a
more resilient city so when you build
back you have to build back stronger the
Magnificent thing that the people of the
city have done is they didn't build the
city back the way it was they built it
the way it should have always been if we
would have gotten it right the first
time and so as you see us rebuilding our
schools rebuilding a health care
delivery systems rebuilding an economic
development rebuilding our government
the city has successfully turned itself
around and it's moving in the right
direction now and we're doing pretty
well although the challenge now is how
to move a forward how to become part of
the 21st century knowledge-based economy
and not leave anybody behind and that's
what we're working on now tell us
briefly the story of Circle food and why
it's a circle food was was a historic
african-american business that provided
groceries to folks in the seventh Ward
which is one of our oldest historic
african-american neighborhoods it got
beat up beat to hell by the storm just
like everything else came in Duane
Boudreaux who was the owner of that said
I'm not cashing out I'm staying I'm not
gonna borrow a bucket load of money I'm
gonna wait we put together a team of
people to work with him and through
federal state and local work through his
work through works of other financial
institutions we were able to help him
stand back up and he's really become an
anchor of that community again and it's
a really wonderful story about what he's
doing there and how well his business is
doing and he's also helping us in the
9th Ward as well so I want to talk a
little politics got big in your state
sure
a lot of legacy talk in American
politics today you got a Clinton and a
Bush running here from a pretty famous
political family how many elections did
your dad ever lose I don't know that you
lost any how many of you watched I've
lost two you've lost two and your
sisters just lost you lost one so what's
your sense of in our current political
culture every state is different but
nationally is having a famous political
name a good thing is it an advantage or
is it a bad well it's it's both it cuts
both ways because you take the good in
the bad I mean generally speaking name
recognition you know goes a long way and
the more people you know the better at
the same time you buy the liabilities of
other people that you've worked with I
mean in families you love and adore the
people who are part of your family you
work with them you weren't making a
bunch of separate entities as well it is
really a net positive though because at
the end of the day it's really the
experience that matters the public gets
kind of tired sometimes and they want
something new from time to time and at
the end of the day it's not going to
save you the only thing it does is get
your foot in the door you've got to
perform and you have to perform well and
you have to earn your stripes every day
we got to get our viewers who have never
been to your city as jazzed up as I am
to always picture I mean it's just it
was spectacular first thing
teach me to prance the name of your city
N'awlins dollars no it's just real easy
ladies knowledge that's that no yeah not
New Orleans not New Orleans just
knowledge just always better Princeton
in your state Louisiana Louisiana yeah
Louisiana Louisiana okay it depends on
what part of the state you from you call
it Louisiana but N'awlins Louisiana yeah
just let it rip easy that's it that's
all right I know you love all your all
your children equally but what's the
last great meal where where did you have
the last great restaurant meal in your
city oh we knew all it doesn't matter
any restaurant spectacular why I've
never get answers like this to your
elicit city but you're not feeding this
out how can you have such good food so
many good restaurants in one city had it
today it's not only that but how can the
city lose people and have six hundred
more restaurants after Katrina they had
before and it's not just because we have
a joy of life in a joy of food we know
how to enjoy things difficult don't have
a joy of life I think they have a
wonderful joy a lot but it's not what
they have in New Orleans not explain it
to me it's a tiny little city there
aren't that many ppl we know how to eat
or the why like where does it come from
and that drives in incredible
restauranteurs it's really super you'll
get a great pizza let's talk about let's
talk about this how do the city of New
Orleans can take the joy of life and
turn it into economic development and
growth in our city the cultural economy
art music food fun it's a five billion
dollar in Jersey get seventy eighty
thousand along with an eighty thousand
people the biggest industry and and it
really is about the business of
entertaining people sports entertainment
we've done more Super Bowls than
anywhere else except Miami and we should
get the next one if Roger Goodell is
listening and and it really is important
that when you think about the business
side of culture what New Orleans really
means to the rest of the world that's
one of the reasons why the world gas
with the possibility they would actually
lose what they call the soul of the
nation no one's a very important part of
this country we're very thankful by the
way to the people of America for helping
us stand up in the k10 anniversary the
Katrina 10 is going to be to commemorate
the lives lost right to thank people for
everything that they've done for us and
then to pivot and to look forward to our
300th anniversary which of course is
just going to be in three years because
of course we were here before the rest
of the country and and we want to really
be a model for the rest of America in
all of the things that we're doing in
terms of education health care economic
development and particularly resilience
how cities learn how to live through
difficult times and how to stand
themselves back up love what you're
doing with the emphasis on education
health care because pre-katrina you were
not a leader no not at all neither of
those areas we want a leader in much of
anything yeah before the storm but New
Orleans now is in ascendant City I think
anybody that comes into our city
notwithstanding our barnacles and not
sending that we still have same promises
everybody else you wanted a city that
was at worst and we're going to first
Bloomberg has recognized us that way
forbes has recognized us that way The
Wall Street Journal
more people are moving into the city
than a leaving GDP is growing faster our
sales tax is growing fast our jobs are
growing fast our education system has
been recalibrated it's a pretty amazing
story of not only surviving right not
only resurrection but actually turning
yourself around and actually becoming
the city that you always should have
been if you would have gotten it right
the first time